Guten Abend. Ich heiße Mustafa Günig. Ich bin hier auf der Station Assistenzastätich.
Ich würde gerne das Anamnese gespricht führen. Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, natürlich. Hauptsache, jemand hilft mir. Klar.
Ja, ja. Wir sind für Sie da. Machen Sie sich nicht keine Sorge.
Bevor Ihre Aktuelle bespricht werden, würde ich Ihre persönliche Daten dokumentieren.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Magdalena Schmidt.
Magdalena mit M-A-G.
D-A-L-E-N-A.
Sorry, sorry.
Magdalena und Schmidt mit D-T.
Ja, Schmidt, Schmidt ein bisschen originell mit Doppeltier am Ende.
Doppeltier, ja, so farg.
Frau Schmidt, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 56 Jahre.
56, wann sind Sie genau geworden?
Am 11.06.68.
16.06.1960.
Okay. Frau Schmidt, wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 168.
Wie viel wiegen Sie so seit?
Ja, so 79 kg.
79 kg.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Was bilden Sie so uns? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, wissen Sie, ich habe mit einem ganz geschwollenen Arm rechts.
Ich habe das Gefühl, es wird immer mehr.
Das hat vor einigen Tagen angefangen.
Der tut mir auch weh.
Jetzt ist es auch gerötet, vor allen Dingen hier in den Oberarm,
aber eigentlich der ganze Arm.
Und der spandt.
Ich kann ihn eigentlich auch gar nicht mehr so gut bewegen.
Das ist alles, wie so, als ob es durch die Schwellung so festgefressen ist.
Ja, und das ist mir jetzt unheimlich.
Da habe ich gedacht, ich komme doch mal zu Ihnen.
Seit wann haben Sie die Beschwerden?
Ja, das hat angefangen vor 2, 3 Tagen.
Ja, und dann habe ich erst gedacht,
naja, gut, hast du vielleicht ein bisschen viel gearbeitet.
Aber dann ist es eben immer schlimmer geworden.
Das ist eben so, dass ich den Arm praktisch gar nicht mehr richtig bewegen kann.
Und es tut auch richtig weh.
Wo genau die Schmerzen?
Eigentlich ist dieses Spannungsgefühl und diese Schmerzen im ganzen Arm.
Das ganze Arm.
Wie gerötet und überwalt haben Sie bemerkt?
Ja, das ist auch heiß der Arm, ja.
Okay, ich frage mich.
Gibt es auslöserliche Messen, die Beschwerden haben Sie sich erinnern?
Ob ich mich erinnern kann?
Also ich habe da jetzt zum Beispiel keine Verletzung oder so was.
Ich habe mich nicht gestoßen.
Also, ja klar, ich habe ein bisschen im Garten gearbeitet,
aber jetzt nicht irgendwie besonders viel.
Da habe ich erst gedacht, naja, gut, hast du ein bisschen Muskelkater,
aber das ist eben jetzt immer mehr geworden.
Okay.
Wann haben Sie stark in der Garten gearbeitet?
Vor zwei Tagen.
Okay.
Dann fangen Ihre Beschwerden an, oder?
Ja, ungefähr so, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie einen kleinen Stich bemerkt oder W-Stich oder Säckernstich?
Ein Säckernstich, meinst ich, ist mir nicht aufgefallen,
aber ich meine klar, im Garten krabbelt immer irgendwas um,
aber ich trage eigentlich auch immer Handschuhe bei der Arbeit.
Also, wie aufgefallen ist mir nichts.
Okay.
Wie beschreiben Sie Beschwerden,
genau sind Sie echter dumpf, steckend, brennend oder...
Ne, brennend, brennend steckend, nicht eher so dumpf, drückend,
dass ich so ein Druck- und Spannungsgefühl in dem Arm habe.
Wie schätzen Sie die Schmerzintensität ein vorbei,
ein bis zehn, ein sehr leichter
und sehr starker Schmerz in der Sprache?
Ne, also, ich kann den Arm schon wirklich nicht gut bewegen
und bin da wegen der Schmerzen eingeschränkt.
Ich würde schon sagen über die Hälfte, also so bei sechs ungefähr.
Okay.
Ist die ganzen Arme gerötet, oder?
Ja, also gerötet ist vor allen Dingen der Ober- und der Unterarm.
Die Hand ist im Augenblick nur geschwollen,
aber die ist noch nicht so gerötet.
Besonders unterarm.
Der Ober- und Unterarm sind beide gerötet und geschwollen.
Okay.
Können Sie, sind Sie ein Amisendraubchen oder Krippen?
Ne, das habe ich jetzt nicht, nein.
Und Taubheißgefühl haben Sie bemerkt?
Ne, Taub ist die Hand eigentlich auch nicht, ne?
Ah, okay.
Fraugschmidt haben Sie es noch etwas Ungeründiges bemerkt,
von denen ich wissen musste?
Ne, das ist eigentlich, also wie gesagt, der Arm ist geschwollen
und ich kann mich, ich kann den nicht gut bewegen
und jetzt ist er mir eigentlich lästig, weil er so schwer ist
und sich nicht bewegen lässt, ist er eigentlich immer im Weg.
Ah, okay.
Haben Sie weitere Beschwerden zum Beispiel
Schlafstörung, Appetitossigkeit,
ein Fieber, Schüttelfrost?
Fieber oder Schüttelfrost, also ich habe heute Nacht nicht so gut geschlafen,
weil ich halt die Schmerzen hatte und immer gucken musste,
wo ich den Arm hin, ja, aber, also, dass ich jetzt,
dass ich jetzt generell Schlafstörung habe
oder Fieber kann ich jetzt nicht behaupten, ich habe nicht gemessen,
aber ich fühle mich überhaupt nicht fieberig.
Okay, haben Sie in der letzten Seite Gewichtverlust?
Ne, eigentlich bin ich stabil mit dem Gewicht.
Ah, okay.
Haben Sie Herzrasen oder Luftnot?
Ne, so, was habe ich alles nicht, zum Glück.
Okay, gut.
Haben Sie Verstöpfung oder Durchwahl?
Sie meinen jetzt Verdauungsbeschwerden?
Nein, also, normalerweise habe ich keine Probleme
und jetzt im Augenblick auch nicht.
Okay, daraufhin haben Sie schon einmal solche Beschwerden gehabt?
Kann ich mich nicht erinnern, dass ich schon einmal solche Beschwerden hatte, ne?
Erste Mal, okay, richtig.
Gut, frage ich Sie mit, leiden Sie ein Brunscher
vor Erkrankungen wie zum Beispiel Brutzucker,
Bluthockdruck oder Schichtdruck?
Ja, ich habe natürlich ein bisschen hohe Blutwertwerte
und habe auch ein bisschen erhöhten Blutdruck
und was wahrscheinlich auch noch wichtig ist,
ich hatte vor, ja, es ist jetzt schon lange her,
vor 14 Jahren hatte ich eine Brustoperation.
Eine Brustoperation, ja.
Wegen was?
Ja, wegen Brustkrebs.
Okay, ja, okay, richtig.
Vor 14 Jahre.
Das ist 14 Jahre her, genau.
Seit wann haben Sie Bluthockdruck und Blutwertwerte?
Also, der Bluthockdruck, den hat man damals im Rahmen
dieser Operation, hat man das festgestellt
und da habe ich dann auch Medikamente bekommen.
Und jetzt vor, also 5 Jahre später,
hat man dann auch gemerkt, dass eben auch die
Kollesterinwert eben ein bisschen zu hoch ist.
Okay, seit 5 Jahren ungefähr.
Und beide OP, ihre Achselböre
und Lämpfknoten entfernt?
Ja.
Ja, okay.
Und was wurden Sie ganz genau damals behandelt?
Ich eigentlich.
Also überwiegend, überwiegend die Operation
und kurzfristig, ganz kurzfristig der Nachbestrahlung.
Strahlen, Therapie, meine Sie.
Dann alles in Ordnung?
Ja, also seither sind die Kontrollen alle in Ordnung, ja.
Oh Gott sei Dank, das fragt mich sehr.
Was nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder gelegenlich ein?
Ich nehme Concours 5 ein.
Und bitte?
Könnten Sie langsam nochmal buchstabieren?
Concours 5, ja, C-O-N-C-O-R,
beschreiben wir das.
Ja, okay.
Und dann, dann nehme ich morgens eine.
Und dann habe ich noch Diowahn,
das ist mein ich auch gegen Bluthochdruck.
Okay.
Und dann, weil ich hin und wieder Ärger hat mit Heuschnupfen,
habe ich noch so ein Medikament,
das ich dann bei Bedarf einnehmen kann, das heißt Zetirizin.
Zetirizin, bei Bedarf.
Welche Dosien nehmen Sie, den Concours Diowahn und Zetirizin ein?
Bei Zetirizin kann ich Ihnen gar nicht sagen,
weil ich das meine ich immer eben nur nach Bedarf nehme.
Und Concours 5, eine morgens.
Und Diowahn, das sind Hundert Dächtige,
nehme ich auch eine morgens.
Das ist eine morgens.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert außer Ambulustentwärmung?
Ja, vor einem Jahr hatte ich auch noch eine Hüftoperation
auf der rechten Seite.
Also ich habe eine neue Hüftgelenk bekommen.
Vor einem Jahr.
Das ist aber zum Glück alles sehr gut verlaufen.
Und jetzt kann ich wieder schmerzfrei gehen.
Super.
Und das war es, oder?
Ja, das war es.
Das war lange auch wirklich her.
Frau Schimit, rauchen Sie?
Nein, rauchen, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Noch nie.
Ich habe mir nie geschmeckt, habe ich nie probiert.
Super.
Trinken Sie gelegenen oder regelmäßig Alkohol?
Also regelmäßig würde ich das nicht nennen,
also sehr gelegen, ich glaube.
Was trinken Sie gelegen?
Ja, eigentlich kommt ein bisschen drauf an,
was es zu essen gibt.
Im Sommer trinke ich gerne mal ein Glas Bier,
aber auch mal ein Schluck Sex oder auch mal ein Glas Wein.
Und im Winter eigentlich mehr so,
dass man abends mal ein Wein trinkt oder auch mal ein Glühwein
oder sowas.
Okay, verstehe ich.
Nehmen Sie die folgende Frage nicht persönlich,
aber Sie haben Kontakt mit Drogen?
Mit Drogen?
Nein, mit Drogen habe ich noch erst dort keinen Kontakt.
Super.
Vielen Dank.
Brauchst Sie mit Leben Ihre Eltern auf?
Nein, mein Vater ist ganz früh gestorben.
Woran ist er gestorben?
Er hat den Herz infarbt.
Und er war noch keine 60, also er ist wirklich früh gestorben.
Okay, Herr Herzchenbeileid.
Und meine Mutter lebt noch?
Die hat genau wie ich auch eine neue Hüfte bekommen
auf der einen Seite.
Und damit kommt sie aber ganz gut zurecht.
Und ich weiß, dass die auch etwas gegen hohen Blutdruck nehmen muss.
Ja, ich habe jetzt noch eine Schwester.
Und ich hatte einen Bruder, der ist auch eigentlich früh
verstorben, an einem Herzinfarkt.
Ah, er ist infarkt.
Das ist wirklich sehr leid.
Und meine Schwester hat eine kleine Mutter.
Und sie hat eine kleine Mutter.
Und meine Schwester, die ist ein bisschen jünger als ich.
Und da hat man dann vor einem Jahr eben auch Brustkrebs festgestellt.
Und die ist noch in der Behandlung.
Ja, die Familie lässt nichts aus.
Alles in Ordnung bei ihr?
Ja, so weit hat sie es, glaube ich, überstanden.
Ja, aber richtig durchatmen kann man natürlich noch einiges.
Ja, aber richtig durchatmen kann man natürlich nach einem Jahr noch nicht.
Okay, verstehe ich.
Was ist die von Büro?
Ich bin Reiseverkehrskaufraue.
Ich arbeite also im Reisebüro.
Und jetzt haben wir auch wieder etwas zu tun.
Bei Corona war es ein bisschen öde.
Aber jetzt sind wir wieder auf dem Größten raus und die Leute verreisen wieder.
Das heißt, arbeiten Sie selbstständig?
Nein, ich bin angestellt in einem Reisebüro.
Ah, okay.
Ich arbeite aber auch nicht vollzeit.
Ich arbeite nur eine halbe, ich habe nur eine halbe Stelle.
Oh, das ist super.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben drei Kinder.
Aber die sind natürlich auch schon groß.
Ja, drei erwachsene Kinder.
Sind Sie hoffentlich gesund?
Sie sind alle gesund, ja.
Na gut.
Also noch ein paar Fragen.
Haben Sie eine Allergie außer Heuschnupfen?
Oder um Technik?
Also, die Heuschnupfen, das ist ein bisschen das Einzige.
Sonst wüsste ich jetzt nicht, dass ich auf jeden Fall aller Geschreie reagiere.
Okay.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft gegen Kinderkrankheiten oder gegen Covid?
Gegen Covid bin ich geimpft, ja, klar.
Und ja, also die Kinderkrankheiten, das liegt natürlich schon lange zurück.
Aber ich glaube, alles, was man so machen kann,
jetzt aktuell, also selbst gegen, gegen hier diese, diese Zeckenstichgeschichte,
da bin ich auch geimpft.
Also alles, was man eigentlich so aktuell machen soll, habe ich gemacht.
Okay, richtig.
Sind Sie in der letzten Seite im Ausland gewesen?
Nein, überhaupt nicht. Nein, gar nicht.
Okay. Wir sind fast fertig, Frau Schmidt.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Ja, ich will natürlich jetzt schon wissen, warum der Arm so geschwollen ist
und vor allem, was man dagegen tun kann, ja.
Und ob man natürlich auch wieder normal in meinem Alltag zurechtkommen will?
Ja, ich verstehe Ihre Sorge.
Aber es ist so früh etwas genau zu sagen, wir müssen ein paar Untersuchungen,
die zum Beispiel Bullets-Untersuchungen,
körperliche Untersuchungen und vielleicht Bildgebände verfahren durchführen.
Deswegen bitte ich Sie ein wenig geduld.
Ja, sobald wir alle Ergebnisse erhalten haben,
werde ich mit meinem Oberarzt über Ihren Fall besprechen
und dann werde ich Sie Schritt für Schritt informieren.
Ja, das ist gut, ja.
Dass ich weiß, wie es weitergeht.
Genau, sehr gut.
Nehmen Sie einen Platz, bitte.
Untersuchung zu meinen. Ich komme gleich.
Sehr gut, okay.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Jetzt haben wir 37 Kollegen.
Ich habe Fragen.
Doch kommt eine Frage, ja.
Also, wann war Ihre letzte Tetona im Funk, erinnern Sie sich?
Das ist schon lange her, lassen Sie mich überlegen.
Das ist bestimmt fünf Jahre her.
Okay.
Tetanos, was bedeutet Deutsch?
Wunsch-Tatanus.
Ich weiß, aber...
Ach so.
Deswegen, Patiente fragen, müssen wir...
Ja, aber eigentlich ist Tetanos geläufig.
Okay.
Also Wunsch-Tatanus wissen, glaube ich, die wenigsten.
Aber Tetanos-Impfungen wissen eigentlich die...
Also, wenn man vom Hund gebissen wird oder von der Katze oder so,
dann weiß man, man muss zur Tetanos-Impfung in die Klinik gehen.
Bei der Prüfung, Frage diese...
Ja, das kann gut, das stimmt.
Das kann gut sein, dass die Frage kommt, ja.
Ich habe noch eine andere Frage.
Ja?
Wenn Sie...
Wo genau hat der Beschwerden eingepangen im Arm?
Im Hand oder im Arm?
Nee, nicht in der Hand. Die Spällung ist von oben runtergekommen.
Ja, Sie haben schon gesagt.
Okay.
Noch andere Fragen, Kollegen?
Ja, ich würde fragen, wann wurden Sie das letzte Mal
auf Buskrebs untersucht?
Ah, gute Frage.
Ja, gynäkologische Kontrolluntersuchung.
Ja, ich gehe regelmäßig zum Gynäkologen
und die letzte Untersuchung ist im Frühjahr gewesen,
also halbis Jahr her.
Und da war alles in Ordnung, zum Glück.
Die Patientin hat gesagt, eine oder zwei Bundesentfernung.
Rechte Seite, hat sie gesagt.
Okay.
Ich habe noch eine Frage, wenn Sie Seite haben.
Ja, natürlich.
Haben Sie eine...
Also, ändern Sie sich, was war damals Ihre Medikamente
für die Buskrebs?
Oh, das kann ich nicht mehr sagen, das weiß ich nicht mehr.
Hier kommt noch die Frage, ob ich schon mal Lymphdrainage hatte.
Ja.
Eine Schokoladenfrage für mich, ja.
Genau.
Also, jetzt muss ich überlegen, ob ich das schon mal hatte.
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass ich schon mal Lymphdrainage hatte.
Kollegen hat gefragt, ob es in Strahlung oder Linderung...
Ausstrahlung.
Ausstrahlung und Linderung.
Ja, also, die Sperren strahlen nicht aus.
Und Linderung, ja, eigentlich.
Die Patientin hat zum Beispiel Medikamenteingenommen.
Nein, ich habe kein Medikamenteingenommen.
Aber was ein bisschen hilft, wenn ich den Arm halt lagere,
wenn er nicht sein eigenes Gewicht tragen muss.
Ja, dann fühlt sich das ein bisschen besser an.
Wenn ich ihn also zum Beispiel im Bett auf dem Kissen ablegen kann
oder wenn ich umlaufe,
selber so ein bisschen mit dem anderen Arm stütze,
dann tut das weniger weh, als wenn der Arm runterhängt.
Das war, ich denke, alle Fragen gestattet.
Enkao.
Ja.
Ich habe noch eine letzte Frage, wenn Sie sagen.
Haben Sie eine blauliche Verfassung der Hände oder Finger bemerkt?
Ne, eine blauliche Verfassung.
Ich habe nur eine Rötung des Armes bemerkt.
Und ja, vielleicht, das kann man auch ergänzend sagen,
dass die Haut auch so glänzend ist, ja.
Aber die Finger sind nicht blau.
Okay, ja, danke.
Wir sagen, Geröte geschwollen überwärmt.
Ja, okay, danke schön.
Hatten Sie schon einmal eine Schwerlung im betroffenen Arm?
Hat er gefragt, hatte ich aber noch nicht.
Doch nicht, nur Schwerlung.
Ja, nicht Rötung oder...
Ne, also hatte ich aber auch früher nicht.
Da war ja auch die Frage, ob ich Lymphdrenner hatte.
Deswegen habe ich die Frage verneint.
Der Arm war also unauffällig nach der OP.
Okay.
Könnten wir Arsatzgeschichte anfangen?
Ja, ich hoffe sehr.
Bitte schön.
Schönen guten Abend, Frau Oberestin.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Aber sie haben eine kurze Zeit Patientin vorgestellt.
Ja, natürlich, wen haben Sie gesehen?
Ja, Frau Martellena Schmidt.
Eine 56-jährige Patientin stellte sich bei uns in der Notaufnahme
von der bremenden Oberrechtenarm Schmerz.
Zu dem klackte sie über rechten Arm-Ödem, Erditeem, Überwarmung.
Weiterhin berichtete der Patientin eine Bewegung-Anschränkung.
Die Frage nach Vagetative Anamnese war eine Insomnia.
Ansonsten war die Vagetative Anamnese unauffällig.
An vor Erkrankungen berichtete sie seit fünf Jahren an eine Hyperlipidemie,
seit fünf Jahren an arterielle Hyperlponie
und vor vierzehn Jahren an eine Mammekarsenung zu leiden.
Dagegen nimmt sie regelmäßig von kurz fünf Milligramm morgens,
die oberen 160 Milligramm morgens und Siterizin bei Bedarf ein.
Siterizin, warum?
Siterizin nimmt sie gegen Rhinoconjuktivitis.
An vor Operationen hatte sie vor einem Jahr ein rechte Hüft-Tab.
Sie hat noch nie geraut.
Sie trinkt sehr geregentlich ein Bier, ein Flasche Bier,
eine Drohungkunden wurde verneint.
Familien an Amnestisch fand sich ein Hüft-Tab und arterielle Hyperlponie
bei der Mutter, eine Mammekarsenung,
beide ihre Schwester.
Sie berichtete weiterhin, dass ihr Bruder und ihr Vater
an Myokartinfarkt verstorben sind.
Werblich ist sie als Reisevorarbeiterin tätig.
Sie ist verheiratet und hat drei gesunde Erwachsene Kinder.
Der Impfstatus der Patientin ist vollständig.
Das war meine Seite.
Was hat sie jetzt?
Was ist Ihre Verdacht-Zirjagnose?
Eine Lufttrainagen-Obsturzion.
Oder eine Lebstau.
Das könnte auch ein Worst-Case sein.
Was ist ein dickes Bein?
Es könnte auch eine Borrelidos sein.
Wenn Sie jetzt ein geschwollenes Bein hätten,
dann denken Sie, es könnte auch sein,
eine Trombose.
Was machen Sie mit der Patientin?
Sie haben eine körperliche Untersuchung.
Was machen Sie erst mal?
Eine gerötete Stelle?
Oder eine gerötete Extremität?
Was machen Sie noch?
Eine Durchblutung, eine Motoreksensibilität.
Und vergleichen den anderen.
Ein Problem und eine Überwärmung.
Die Überwärmung können Sie ja nur fühlen.
Ich meine noch etwas anderes.
Bei der Inspektion meinen Sie?
Ein Blaufleck oder eine Offene Wunde.
Ob sie eine Wunde hat, ein Hautriss.
Oder muss man genau gucken.
Bei der Apparativuntersuchung,
ein Doktor-Sonografie,
ich habe eine Durchblutung und eine Trombose.
Wo nehmen Sie das Blut ab?
Ein gesunder Oberwärmung mit einer linken Seite.
Was erwarten Sie, wenn Sie vermuten, ein RCP?
Das haben Sie als Diagnose gesagt.
Ein bestimmter Erwartung im Labor.
Ein Rötung, eine besondere Grenze im Oberal.
Das hat Sie ja beschrieben.
Aber für ein RCP braucht es eine Eintrittsforte.
Ein erhebliches Krankheitsgefühl und Fieber.
Was wäre die Therapie, wenn Sie tatsächlich ein RCP hat?
Eine stationäre Aufnahme, IV-Zugang, Flüssigkeit zuvor, wenn es nötig.
Eine Antibiotika, Anallgetika und Hochlagerung.
Eine gute Wünfte.
Was würde man machen?
Eine Kältekompression.
Ich weiß, dass das jetzt Frust ist, aber ich muss Sie ein bisschen korrigieren.
Mir gefällt die Einleitung nicht, weil Sie eigentlich keinen richtigen Satz sagen.
Sie haben den Schwerpunkt, warum die Patientin zu Ihnen kommt.
Sie haben sie anders gesetzt als die Patientin.
Die Patientin ist gekommen und hat gesagt, mein Arm ist geschwollen, heiß und rot und tut mir weh.
Sie haben gesagt, sie kommt wegen Schmerzen im rechten Arm.
Die Schmerzen hat sie auf, aber das ist nicht das Hauptsymptom.
Krass auffällig ist der dick geschwollene Arm, glänzend rot, heiß.
Das muss als erste Info kommen.
Bei der Patientin besteht Zustand nach Mammakarsenomen rechts.
Das dürfen Sie nicht erst unter fernaliefen sagen.
Zumal Sie gesagt haben, bei Vorerkrankungen, da kam das dann, haben Sie gesagt,
Sie haben seit 17 Jahren eine Brustoperation, hatte sie Mammakarsenomen.
Und dann haben Sie seit Jahr und Voroperation vor einem Jahr die Hüftapp.
Haben Sie die Brust-OP nicht erwähnt?
Die Kausalität liegt ja so ziemlich auf der Hand.
Das ist so ein Zusammenhang, den man eigentlich nicht ignorieren darf.
Wie gesagt, das Hauptsymptom des Patienten muss schon nach vorne.
Dass die Patientin hat sich vorgestellt mit der Signifikantin Arm-Ödem,
das zu einer Bewegungseinschränkung führt und auch Schmerzen macht.
Dann kam das ganze andere hinterher, besteht seit zwei Tagen.
Sie hat im Garten gearbeitet.
Wunde ist ihr nicht aufgefallen.
Das können dann hinterherrücken.
Aber da muss die Reihenfolge schon wirklich stimmen.
Was mich auch gewundert hat, Sie haben gesagt, Sie hätten brennende Schmerzen.
Ich habe ausdrücklich gesagt, brennen und stechen tut es nicht, sondern es drückt.
Es ist schon auch wichtig, korrekt das wiederzugeben.
Was der Patient wirklich gesagt hat.
Das war das mit der Brust-Op. Das war ganz wichtig.
Ich finde schon bei der Familienanahmnese, wäre das schon auch wichtig,
dass der Vater jung war, als er den Herzinfarkt gehabt hat.
Und der Bruder, der ja wahrscheinlich ungefähr im gleichen Alter ist.
Dass beide am Herzinfarkt verstorben sind, gibt es eine familiäre Neigung.
Ansonsten gibt es eben Parallelen mit der Schwester, die auch erkrankt ist.
Dann Augenblick, den Häuschnupfen haben Sie auch nicht so richtig erwähnt.
Das fällt mir gerade etwas ein und auf.
Was Sie nicht erwähnt haben bei den Laborwerten, was bestimmt werden muss,
die Dedimere natürlich.
Für den Thrombose-Ausschluss.
Augenblick, ich hatte, ah, ja, bei der Sozialanahmnese, sie ist Reiseverkehrskauf-Frau.
Wir haben gesagt, sie ist Reisebüroarbeiterin.
Das trifft den Kern nicht so richtig.
Arbeiter sind Leute, die ganz einfache Arbeiten verrichten.
Und Angestellte, sie ist ja eine qualifizierte Mitarbeiterin.
Also ist die Bezeichnung Arbeiterin sicherlich nicht richtig.
Man kann sagen, sie arbeitet in einem Reisebüro, das kann man natürlich sagen.
Aber man sollte nicht Reisebüroarbeiterin sagen.
Sie hat gesagt, sie ist Reiseverkehrskauf-Frau.
Das ist das Gegenstück von Kaufmann.
Es gibt halt viele merkwürdige Berufe in Deutschland.
Einer meiner Lieblingsberufe ist die Bäckerei Fachverkäuferin.
Man kann einem also einen schönen Titel geben, ist ja alles schön und nett.
Aber wie gesagt, der Arbeiterklasse gehören die Leute einfach nicht so gerne an.
Das hört sie zwar nicht im Arztgespräch, aber trotzdem sollte man das irgendwie gescheit wiedergeben.
Ja, ganz am Anfang vom Arzt-Patient-Gespräch machen sie eine Formulierung.
Ich vergesse die immer wieder zu schnell.
Aber da fehlt auch immer irgendwie ein Wort.
Sie sagen, bevor wir über ihre Beschwerden sprechen, brauche ich ein paar persönliche Daten.
Da muss man vollständige Formulierung hin.
Dass man also sagt, wir sprechen gleich über ihre Beschwerden.
Vorher brauche ich ein paar Angaben zu ihrer Person.
Vielleicht können Sie es noch mal anfören in der Aufzeichnung, dass Sie wissen, was ich meine.
Irgendwie fehlt da immer etwas.
Ist mir beim letzten Mal schon aufgefallen, habe ich aber verpennt zu sagen.
Das war es aber jetzt auch.
Das war jetzt sehr nörgelig.
Ich will Ihnen nicht den Moral kaputt machen für morgen.
Wirklich nicht.
Aber es war heute nicht so gut wie letztes Mal. Ehrlich nicht.
Ja, und insofern beherzigen Sie die paar Punkte, die ich Ihnen gesagt habe.
Und horchen Sie vielleicht noch mal kritisch unser Gespräch heute Abend an.
Dann wissen Sie, glaube ich, was ich meine.
Und morgen wird es super.
Und Sie kriegen auch keine Phlebitis und kein Lymphodeen.
Unsere Kollegen haben alle notwendigen Fragen gestellt.
Aber dann müssen wir als erstes 20 Minuten denken und danach als erstes Gespräch anfangen.
Aber diese Simulation haben wir keine Zeit.
Ja, das stimmt natürlich.
Sie haben dann in der Prüfung mehr Zeit.
Nur, also mir ging das jetzt darum, einfach die relevanten Sachen,
dass die in der Erstinformation für den ärztlichen Kollegen kommen.
Das muss wirklich sein.
Und ja, es ist übrigens ein Mainzer Fall.
Ja, ja.
Und es ist nicht aufgeklärt, ob es tatsächlich eine Phlebitis oder Lymphödem ist.
Ja, und was Sie vielleicht nicht wissen, sondern die Kollegen,
die schon viele, viele Jahre bei mir zuhören, dass ich die letzten fünf
Jahre meiner Berufstätigkeit in einer Lymphspreistromge gearbeitet habe.
Insofern ist das natürlich bei Schokoladenthema.
Und ja, deswegen liegt mir der Fall am Herzen.
Und ich war eigentlich sehr begeistert zu sehen, dass die Mainzer einen Lymphödemfall haben.
Ja.